Buddha Fest is the largest city on the
Danube the Fisherman's Bastion in the
castle district is one of gob our
Bulldog skis favorite landmarks he was
born in Sega din southern Hungary but
has been living in Budapest for 20 years
Rosanna we should take a look at this
beautiful city Amanda Daniel which flows
through a condition of don't over the
forest only yeah it's a city with a lot
of history 44 you so many different
people have lived here and shared the
city kasama on the mix of cultures is
interesting and quite appealing a
fountain show built in 2005 the palace
of the Arts is another cultural
highlight of the city Bulldog he
performs at the high-profile venue at
least once a year the star trumpeter in
his organist put on an exclusive concert
for an audience of one
and then misha gets his very first
trumpet lessons straight from the master
look what makes for a good trumpet
player oath yo I breathe out and as I
breathe out my lips vibrate Budapest was
formed from two separate cities on
opposite sides of the Danube Buda and
pest which joined in the 19th century
today the city is home to about 1.7
million people st. stephen's basilica is
the largest church in the city it can
hold up to 8,500 people and the dome is
almost a hundred meters high bulldog he
is fascinated by the architecture of the
cathedral which took almost 50 years to
build next up let's tear em one of the
loveliest cafes in the city it's also
one of Bulldog skis favorite haunts
mainly because of the pastries they're
among his great passions alongside music
we take a look at our report from 2007
back then we met gaba Bulldog ski at the
Spring Festival in Budapest he had
already won numerous prizes and was
being feted as the successor to the
famous French trumpeter Maurice Andre
since that time there's been a German
record industry award and album of the
month and a post at budapest renowned
franz liszt music academy to name just a
few of his honours mattresses does that
make it easier to work or is it harder
because the pressures increased so mum
rafting the positive in pulsar looking
for freedom you always need new ideas
I'm happy I can perform all over Europe
and play with good musicians we take the
subway one of Europe's oldest to the
Central Market Hall it's a favorite spot
for grocery shopping we sampled the
salami Bulldog ski says it's a true
hungarian specialty that's uh I'm this
is the coffee the secret is the fabric
on it's not that unique quality that
comes from the Sun Milan the ground red
paprika is what gives it this fabulous
flavor fun delicious dish Marcos
Musha takes along a packet of paprika as
a souvenir for our euromax prize draw
mean wild night has fallen and we return
to the castle district gob Rivaldo ski
takes us to his favorite restaurant 21
which features a modern take on
traditional Hungarian cooking there is
duck liver and of course lush then he
heads home for a practice session
preparing for the next concert in his
ever busy schedule
you